Tôi mấy tôi đang trăm ngày mùi chi thống 3 cho biết đã cố cụ định đàn phòng một giờ
trong hôm vời tổng em ở đây, một bột tiên trong đó 2 bên sau đổi với chiến sự uquan nha và súng đột
ở Iran. Nhìn lấy đau mí mù ta đã đấy là phù chào đổi rất tốt,
giù thương nhận quan hệ giữa mắt sơ và phạm kia, tất cả sòng.
Theo đến Kremlin trong khu đề đàn, tổng em ở đây, bây giờ mình bây giờ,
tổng em đã đưa ra một số đề xuất nhằm đặt được giải pháp chính trị và ngoại giám
nhìn trong trong súng đổi lên quan đến Iran.
Hôm cũng cho biết, Ngá đã cho đổi với lạnh đạo Iran,
các nước vùng vình và nhiều cua ra khác về với đây này.
Về tình hình của quay nà,
thương a cho rằng các bất tiến của cố lội ngà trên trên trường thời gian đầy có thể
thuật ở kia, tiến tờ các cuộc đàn phản nhiên tốt hơn,
giàm hướng tời một thỏa thật hoa bình.
Chong khi đó, tổng thống của quay nà vô lột đi miê dưới đàn xí,
kia sẽ sàng thăm ra các cuộc đàn phản hoa bị bơi nè,
bất tử lúc nào, tuy nhiên của họ bà bên dưới kiện trong plần
đã bị hoán theo đề xuất tự kế miế,
giò các đối tác hiện tập trung và cuộc cuộc hãng Iran.
Hôm dưới lên xíu cụng các buộc,
ngà là tìm cách lối dụng các tham các trung đông để
cải thiện vị thế của mình trong cuộc chiến với u quay nà.